well time is ticking for a full ride at
the university of phoenix
kiersten joyce has the details on why
this scholarship is
only being offered to nevada residents
it's a scholarship for a bachelor's
degree that's only available to nevada
residents
and you've got to get your application
in by this thursday april 15th
the university of phoenix is offering
the scholarship to carry on the legacy
of nevada assemblyman tyrone thompson
he received his master's degree from
university of phoenix and was a huge
champion of education
university of phoenix has a las vegas
campus and if you plan to study
criminology
i.t or business well you'd attend the
majority of classes on campus
and some 70 other degrees are available
online we have a non-traditional
schedule
so with us our bachelor's classes are
five weeks long each class
and you take one at a time so in that
sense some of our students are
able to graduate in less time than four
years but
this scholarship will cover your your
entire bachelor's degree
all applicants must write three short
essays on role models time management
and community service
again the deadline is april 15th i'm
kirsten joyce